[Musique]
on
bon
oui
[Applaudissements]
or
bon ben
elle englobe pour cette première ne
pousse toi mon pote
bienvenue sur des vies qu en direct tous
les soirs on sera là à 18h15 pétantes
on va vous faire revivre tout ce qui
s'est passé dans la journée ils sont
tous partis sont beaux grosse grosse
émotion ce soit parce que ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'on attends moi ça
fait quatre mois je suis chez moi je dis
ça va démarrer quand cette émission non
mais c'est bon quoi j'ai tout fait je
faisais des osso buco à la maison et
darchy parmentier pour ma femme sur la
tête d'une équerre qu'est-ce qu'on est
content d'être là
[Applaudissements]
ellis merci de rejoindre la bande et en
plus sur moi vous avez mis le bracelet
de wonder woman
attention on peut vous tirer dessus
pendant cette émission tous les services
de cinéma dans l'émission je suis très
content s'il vous plaît non brouille
tout de suite
laissez les gens vous apprivoiser jean
michel maire
[Applaudissements]
si bien le faire la capture de julio
iglesias 1978 pour les jeunes qui nous
regarde voilà les ja c'est m pokora se
parer un télé 7 jours un petit peu
malade pour cette première faut le dire
oui mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait pour
être présent j'aurais manqué pour rien
au monde
alors merci pour rien au monde revient à
qui aurait bien aimé que vous manquiez
ainsi christophe carrière de jours à
l'express comme quoi on peut rien [ __ ]
et continuer à bosser je dis les choses
on n'a pas changé le ton de l'émission
c'est le même jour de classe un peu
stressé - vous ai dit c'est ouais bah
oui je pense a dit passage quand on
arrive à vous le faire je parle de lui
c'est pour ça j'en profite
et bien déjà et j'ai vu venir chez moi
ça fait trois minutes c'est pas beaucoup
mieux qu'on a démarré les missions plus
sortait déjà une panne ne comprends pas
tu connaissais l'émission
en fait il n'a pas changé pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas ou à faire là que
vous allez faire la connaissance de
christophe carrière qui ne fera jamais
de spectacles sur coup ce sont des
spectateurs
enora malagré
bonjour
et à côté d'elle jean luc lemoine
ça fait bien
ça fait plaisir que vous ayez fait un
effort et la cravate billes
on m'a dit tu vas voir cyril il anime
des lotos dans les maisons de retraite
c'est des mots qu'ils soient tenus et
pas possible j'ai perdu un pari sur
facebook je vous l'avais bien je ferai
la première en smoking jusqu'à la fin
nous sommes en direct sur d8 je le dit
et on va faire un petit point boubou
parce que vous avez très très nombreux
vous avez été très nombreux à réagir sur
le bon bout on compose tout de suite
avec guillaume eux qui n'ont fait part
d'un reportage sur les moustaches oui je
ferais l'accent du sud comme ça pour la
édition un vote reportage sur les
moustaches dans 100% mag sur m6 on
regarde ça tout de suite je représente
france médard aux autrichiens
damien de rien
lozère et dans la catégorie par des
chinoises les championnats de barbe et
de moustache se divisant 18 catégories
inspirés de traditions nationales comme
la moustache anglaise
[Applaudissements]
voir que ça
les moustaches citoyens acteurs tu veux
faire un reportage sur la moustache
matausch tu pars tu as encore y'a des
trucs chez nous allez on continue avec
sonia qui a repéré un jeune homme dans
l'émission tous différents sur quelle
chaîne tnt un bravo il est plutôt à
l'aise avec son corps et regardez il a
une manière de cuisiner bien à lui est
arrivé le jeune homme laisse son drôle
d'accoutrement pour son costume d'adam
on commence par causer les ingrédients
liquides en cabine avec je mets tout nu
à peu près tous les jours est braquée
narges d'hornu je me lève je vais ouvrir
la porte et ils droit à quelques regards
amusés de livreurs l'udc a créé un blog
de cuisine végétarienne nudistes avec
son colocataire jackson ils cuisinent nu
puis poste les recettes et les photos
sur internet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est seule nuit c'est absolument cas
l'intérêt qu'ont soutenu ses prouesses
regarder pour se montrer mais quand on
est seul chez soi sans passer par une
fille tu fais la cuisine du lait bio à
oui c'est vrai que c'est pas quelle
qu'elle soit n'est pas tout sur une
faute c'est tellement qu'ils soient nus
c'est que le mec s'est déguisé en tigre
ou la journée noire
le mcc et c'est le mec est nu chez lui
quand il sort identique ou mais qui sait
plus sur quel pied danser
allez on continue avec jérôme qui
souhaitent revoir les smac que j'ai
donné à roselyne bachelot et je sais qu
élise est jalouse mais on va regarder ça
ouais ça pince moi ça fait partie de mes
rêves
alors je
c'est ça
oh
je fais je vais faire ce que je fais ce
canton que les émissions maintenant
chaque fois que je suis sur un plateau
desquels je suis obligé de lui faire un
smack c'est roselyne bachelot
et les gars
si je vous dis c'est que j'ai kiffé
maintenant aux idées moi on a cassé et
la monture très fugace petite dédicace
de julien qui nous envoie une vidéo de
danse de l'épaule de l'autre bout du
monde
regardez ça parce que la danse de
l'épaule on va la faire avant la fin de
cette émission avec gad elmaleh notre
invité avec le monde peut vous dire la
danse de l'épaule si on la fait pas dans
cette émission c'est pas touche pas à
mon poste
non c'est d amour ça n'a rien à voir de
la grande muraille en chine
vous voulez passer une petite dédicace à
l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste et en
particulier hamish michmich on kiffe et
pour vous en spéciale dédicace va faire
une petite danse des épaules
[Musique]
les
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
n'ont rien fait de lui l'homme et 2b
même cet été n'ont rien fait de mieux
allez on va accueillir dans un instant
notre avis et gad elmaleh mais pour le
moment c'est ce qu'il fallait pas louper
ce week end à la télé on parlera et
patrick sébastien on n'a pas résisté à
vous faire le perroquet du jour vous
savez patrick sébastien ne peut
s'empêcher de répéter ce que disent les
invités et ben il l'a encore fait samedi
dans le grand camaret attention très
bonne séquence c'est parti le savoir je
te demander de vérifier qu'il a rien
dans la mort hier vers 10h sérieux
vallée blanche
oui alors c'est assez des livres en fait
c'est de lui mais c'est un gamin c'est
un cas c'est un cabinet aussi beaucoup
d'invités en tout cas c'est un plaisir
d'être chez toi c'est un plaisir et ça
s'appelle double double fantasy 7 et 2
ça fait 2-1 contre sion contention
roddick a les cheveux comme moi celui
qui a les cheveux qu'ottawa rien
paraître la saint valentin la casse et
rallye terre mais là il a un vélo il a
fait ça fait un bail que ça fait un
petit buy cave à vin voilà tout on
espère mais les spurs david brécourt et
christian vadim et moi l'homme voilà est
à pop et maintenant l'étape qui sera
toujours
[Applaudissements]
on parlera tout à l'heure de patrick
sébastien parce que c'est en face de
danse avec les stars et danse avec les
stars a cartonné ce sera le jeu zappé je
mate du jour la parodie du jour c'est
groland qu'on aime beaucoup dans cette
émission qui a parodié l'émission
nouveau look pour une nouvelle vie en
nouvelle gueule pour une nouvelle vie
regardez triste et vraiment éclairant
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'il est moche suis
sûr qu'ils font vraiment pringuez comme
une merde pas il faudrait me payer pour
vivre avec un titre pareil
mais pour notre religieuse christine
accorda le rien est impossible même si
sa première rencontre avec klein dabin
montre qu'il va y avoir du travail
[Musique]
c'est tellement pas possible que
finalement notre relooké aux décide de
payer une [ __ ] acklin d'un d'un le soir
même il voulait être loupé sa femme et
ses soies et fatiguent beaucoup et quand
tu as l'air d'en placer une
non c'est pas une blague mais non mais
ça pour moi c'est ça la téléralité pso
c'est la réalité
c'est ça dans la vraie vie c'est ça le
basique non mais tu attends attends mais
c'est parce que cet été en vacances où
j'étais en vacances oui un compagnon
vous êtes en décalage horaire alors je
sais pas où c'était cette campagne non
mais c'est la vérité mais n'a envie de
s'énerver aujourd'hui ça démarre bien sa
poule m allez le carton du jour c'est
vendredi tout est permis et car turquie
rice a cartonné combien wii 2 millions
de téléspectateurs et ça fait 27 % de
part de marché quand même j'ai adoré we
do
sa colère de pur plaisir déviation le
mec s'est dit voilà je voulais passer
mais on se crêpe distraitement oui 2010
et bien il y avait du décor pencher avec
ary abittan et shy'm shy'm je ne m'en
lasse pas on en parlait tout à l'heure
annoncée avec les stars je me demande si
c'est pas la nouvelle madame anna
meshaima nada
bon ma femme qui me regarde je vais
encore perdre des points des abdos face
à l'as pas en face à la pente voilà tu
peux faire des voilà c'est pas si faire
des abdos voilà
ça
par l'échiquier sportif shérif sheriff
orangé il faut ranger il faut ranger
l'appartement mais vous savez que je
sais pas chez vous mais moi je suis pas
pour ça ils m'ont fait
non mais c'est vrai parce qu'ils la
balance comme ça pour toi le mur vous
êtes très sensible quand même si vous
avez eu peur prochaine est très sensible
oui moi j'ai un coeur oui jean luc
lemoine ne sais pas je respecte ça
christophe calme a choisi les dernières
shy'm c'est vrai merci non mais quand
même attendait ça des spectateurs qui
nous rejoignent elle avait choisi mais
là et plus toute sa tête
le m'explique du jour aura bien sûr
parler de m'expliquer car bellemare
c'est vrai en plus
[Applaudissements]
c'est une de mes émissions préférées ça
ça peut être les prochains appels des
enquêtes impossibles sur nt1 alors c'est
toute la journée sur un terrain pierre
bellemare en fait il fait toute la
journée
il est tout le temps là et vous allez
voir que c'est le mec le plus speed du
paf
regardez ces silences c'est encore
magnifique on n'a pas résisté à l'envié
de vous le maître on vous l'avait déjà
fait sain avec pierre bellemare mais
c'est exceptionnel
écoutez bien 1913 sur le coin d'une
table et traces de pneus du désert et
chez la vieille dame
vous me fier
enfin
rendez vous prochainement sur cette
antenne pour un nouvel épisode des
enquêtes impossibles
[Applaudissements]
combret sport mais dans les histoires et
aux fous du vélo c'est bon les laïcs ont
su can deux minutes puisque mondiaux
toutes les 18 minutes sur un bon rythme
c'est ça ouais c'est ça thierry ça
marche bien ça oui ça marche pas mal ça
quand il dit ça c'est qu'ils avaient
tous les jours je vais bien j'ai c'est
un escroc
ça a fait un carton chez les culs de
jatte à montfermeil il était en fête
[Musique]
la première vous êtes malade vous laisse
encore une chance sinon vous sort nous
le dit on finit avec le sourire du jour
c'est une jeune femme qui donne son
secret de beauté au petit journal vous
l'avez vu ça ou pas on ne regarde plus
la télé c'est sa voix qui rallonge à vue
elle sourire les sept sourire ça c'est
pour cette raison que j'allais plus
d'être tellement fashion chez moi
attendez regardez allons regarder ça et
enfin le secret d'un sourire ça aussi
c'est fashion précision cycle beauty
[Applaudissements]
bizarre
et comme ça dans les enterrements tu
vois la rizza si j'ai bien compris vous
avez compris celle ci c'est le côté
c'est tous les messieurs et qui va
partir d'ici très nombreuses attentions
rôle moteur
ça c'est ce qu'il fallait pas louper à
la télé et n'aura à ce qu'il fallait
louper il fallait absolument loupé un
extrait de cette émission absolument
pourri non je ne pouvais pas dire ça non
météo à la carte
j'aime sincèrement mission pour mille
aujourd'hui la météo j'adore les cartons
ben voilà vous êtes servis alors c'est
alexis vous allez voir alexis de toul
qui envoie une vidéo mais plus
soporifiques ont fait pas le garder sa
première oeuvre majeure aujourd'hui
c'est celle d'alexis qui est à toul dans
la meurthe et moselle bonjour alexis je
voudrais que vous tous beaucoup le ciel
est partagé entre passages nuageux et
éclaircies n'est tous les sens on voit
là le ciel aujourd'hui qui nous avons
donc avec des cumulus des atouts qui
pousse un petit nuage qui sont la fin
bref c'est une traîne un peu un ciel
d'averses notamment et on a des rafales
de vent de secteur sud-ouest de 50
km/heure environ aujourd'hui et puis
surtout les températures ce matin car
étaient entre 8 et 10 degrés déjà très
doux et cette communion sont au dessus
des moyennes de saison de 6 à 8 degrés
voilà long et varié
excellente journée à tous ça lui allait
[Applaudissements]
vendredi je crois à la télévision merci
et nora dans un instant gad elmaleh sera
le parrain de cette émission il nous
fait un grand grand honneur d'être dans
touche pas à mon poste mais pour le
moment on accueille celui qui sera avec
nous tous les jours pour son poste de
surveillance camille combal des cours
camille combal c'est un jour agit d un
jeu à givet quant à une mère qui
tricotent même plaisir
on est très très content de recevoir
camille alors qu'à 1000 postes de
surveillance vous avez surveiller quoi
mais juste avant je crois que vous avez
des petites choses à nous montrer un des
petites choses à vous montrer oui avant
le poste de surveillance d'abord comme
chaque jour découvrir un petit peu qui
on a vu à la télévision est aujourd'hui
sur la télévision française nous avons
vu sur bfmtv regarder des nouvelles
coupes d'été qui lui va à ravir
l'essonne montfort jours où tout a
basculé dans les feux de l'amour en
guest star johnny hallyday
c'est lui
ici sur le plateau j'ai très envie de
revoir johnny hallyday qui faisons le
quittera les homes et engine and in et
s'il vous plaît faut la voir ça
s'apprend de 45 minutes à ces
magnifiques voix du balayage c'est un
petit machin mais je sais rien du tout
c'est bien possible je crois qu'on
s'intéresse à masterchef
tout à fait et cirés j'ai décidé de
regarder ce qu'ils connaissent pas
masterchef le principe est simple tu es
chez toi père tu regardes trois gars ce
cas c'est le bide à la télé pendant deux
heures allez
[Musique]
bon bah écoutez on va goûter saint
pascal
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sera pas juste parce que ces trois
là qui se veut un pendant deux heures et
c'est loana qui grossit et ça je ne vote
pas c'est moche je trouve ça juste un
grill à l'amérique c'est vrai c'est vrai
dans masterchef tiens d'ailleurs ils ont
aussi comme nous de très beaux invité
dans masterchef
car dans masterchef ils reçoivent des
stars des stars internationales même si
lille
que dis-je des stars des légendes
vivantes chez tati c'est d'aller souvent
d'accueillir christelle brua
et c'est chez le célèbre artisan
boulanger gontran cherrier que les
candidats vont te vrai jusqu'au petit
matin
merci d'accueillir olivier metz oui la
boulangerie avec les noms les chéris
olivier nasti moi je ne connaissais pas
je suis sûr que les téléspectateurs
connaissent moi je connais c'est jean
claude narcy vous connaissent au décès
samir nasri est connu et reconnu il
avait une boulangerie je crois vers
colin tant et si bien en israël du gaz
aura condamne le roi de la chouquette on
appelle ça comment ça vous l'aurez
olivier piou quête comme d'hab
alors chers pour fait votre émission ces
cinq cabanons olivier nasti vous dites
que vous le connaissez c'est lui qui les
nasty rien et olivier nasti est
probablement le plus brillants
représentants de la jeune cuisine
alsacienne
donc si vous êtes déjà allé en alsace
oui je connaissais pas du tout dit viens
d'afrique est en tout cas qui dit
masterchef dit épreuve compliquée et
cette semaine encore il ya eu des
épreuves où il fallait inventer des
plats toujours plus créatifs regarder 20
minutes c'est le temps qu'il reste aux
candidats pour réussir une pomme va
mieux si vous voulez entendre que je
suis de mauvaise passe
dans sa maison vous verrez qu'ils ont
mis quatre heures pour faire une salade
de fruits j'ai terminé faut que j'y
aille ou comme on dit dans masterchef
c'est pas triché
[Applaudissements]
aux abonnés
bouquet je vous explique vous pouvez
réagir pendant cette émission puisque
les soldes en direct sur twitter http
sur facebook et à mesure sur le look
book vous pouvez dire des choses à nous
dire ce que vous pensez de l'émission
réagir sur ce que ce dont on m'a parlé
et bien c'est l'oiseau tu auteurs qui
sera avec nous tous les autres
[Applaudissements]
merci je vous dire avant la fin de cette
émission je vous ferai découvrir qui se
cache derrière l'oiseau totor vous est
précis et merci j'en ai oublié les
danseuses merci à vous c'est vrai
dans ce
c'étaient les danseuses du soleil des
tropiques voilà je crois qu'elles sont
dans ce chez gilbert montagné ya juste
une volée qui nous dit pierre bellemare
m'a tuer ya marcon qui nous dit dans ce
qu'il fallait pas louper c'était surtout
la coiffure des noirs il ya quatre
chaînes qui twitte je préfère être
torturés par des chatouilles pendant des
heures plutôt que d'avoir des moustaches
comme ça il ya eu du 33 qui nous lie un
truc entre cyril et roselyne bachelot
c'est sûr il ya murrieta murrieta j'aime
beaucoup ton prénom on dirait un
commissariat et chérie tu vas chez tu
m'achètes [ __ ] tu veux prendre des
détails murrieta appelé le baiser de
seville roselyne a les yeux qui brillent
et bien c'est bien la seule femme
qu'elle est vécue les combats
maintenant notre invité l'autre parent
pour cette première sur d8 je vous
rappelle que nous sommes en direct a
réagi cht pmp tout ce que vous voyez sur
tout ce que vous voyez même la robe des
niches à st la coiffure de julio
iglesias tout ça vous le dit sur twitter
et sur book notre invité n'est pas
gaspard proust puisque le comité n'ont
pas dit ça qu'est ce que c'est même s'il
ya de la chienne sur ce plateau
vous allez manquer mais gaspard proust a
changé non savons très bien que
l'émission est en direct est la personne
qui est en régie qui s'appelle cédric
n'a faux voilà c'est un jour aussi un
emploi perdu dans cette émission
et là il me dit dans mon oreille c'est
pas d'ma faute suis pas la technique
mais tu seras chez trop bas
allez notre invité l'époque je viens pas
dit ça va leur en fait c'est quoi c'est
le mec qui est pas assez doux et des
pieds pour faire footballeur pas assez
viril pour jouer au rugby mais assez con
quand même pour jouer au ballon
notre invité à bien du ca vaut qui le
regardait alors on a une bonne question
d'ambition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gad elmaleh qui fait suer en voiture
jusqu'au plateau c'est n'importe quoi
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
dans l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue à cette 32ème
serbie lisette et à la suze dira plus
c'est que voilà j'ai fait un pari sur
twitter c'était assez marrant et j'ai
dit que je resterai en aux papillons
pour toutes les blessures
je vais juste dire à cirer là toute
l'équipe j'étais venu habillé comme ça
pour honorer cette première et et pour
que ça vous porte bonheur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai maintenant une petite danse pour
toi également votre bougez pas on se
retrouve
laurent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme on peut le faire c'est d'être là
ce soir et encore beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui vont arriver et gad elmaleh
notre
jerry gad elmaleh j'ai envie de danser
mais bon si moi aussi quand je te vois
j'ai envie de danser raymond henri
jooris et de faire la fête donnée donner
de l'argent à des familles de faire des
massages à des gens qui ont mal à faire
du bien autour de moi j'ai envie de
chanter genre ou gad elmaleh au québec
au canada les regards des vallées
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu veux faire une chanson sur
mon mari sûr que notre ami m'a dit je te
rappelle que je m'appelle thierry
beccaro
c'est mon cousin hanouna et georges
tolochenaz
pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine jusqu'aux débuts dans la
presse a alors chanté avec des noms de
famille galli n'a pas trouvé tout de
suite voilà tu sais lui
pour bientôt
captée par l'émission parrain de
l'émission serait trop beau non non non
je suis venu pour toi d'ailleurs qu'est
ce tu fais le 15 novembre comme ça t'as
pas de promo le 15 novembre ne sera pas
dans un théâtre le 15 novembre
non mais ni le 17 novembre l'îlot de
vous parrainer que les émissions qui
commence par d'été puisque vous avez
fait le téléthon touche pas à mon poste
vous ferez thé ou café mélenchon je
faire
[Applaudissements]
une émission sur la tarte tatin aussi du
talent c'est rohff et c'est l'émotion
on te retrouves d'attendre que tu as
passé ça là je l'attends avec impatience
mais ce bourg est ce que tu n'entends
pas ce que moi je vous entends pas très
bien j'ai l'impression de crier très
fort tu sais quoi je me mets toujours en
mode envoyé spécial à solferino gareth
bale et je suis actuellement
moi ce que j'adore chez ces mecs là les
envoyés spéciaux
c'est l'assurance avec laquelle ils te
disent qu'il ne se passe rien au corps
c'est ça qu'ils attendent en effet
toujours rien ici
ministère de l'intérieur ont tout le
monde attend et personne n'est sorti
sens total d'événements avec un vix de
foudroyant on reviendra pour de plus
amples détails tout à l'heure toujours
rien ici devant le ministère
[Applaudissements]
complète id artiste id fouet compléter
cet artiste un artiste of new lights of
benetton nous tue c'est donc si j'ouvre
jeu noirmont si on a un petit extrait
quand elle veut aller dans cette fille
elle peut pas s'empêcher de dire à ces
communes
[Musique]
dans l'émission de divertissement je
devrais dire mais tu as trouvé ça aux
reflets cet après midi pour me dire à
l'extrait de 32 secondes tu fais mais je
suis sur les fesses comme à tanger va
juste se tue c'est des trucs incroyables
qu'il roule j'ai un petit extrait je me
suis fait plaisir un voilà je voudrais
faire plaisir aux tests et à ton âme qui
se relaie the glue avait brossé une
casquette 600 tonnes c'est parti le
plomb quand il mange un sandwich
je tends la mayonnaise elle sort pas
lui les tomates elle reste parallèle ya
aucun problème toi tu mords de dans la
feuille de salade elle vient et qui fait
de la mayonnaise partout toi tu as
toujours une tomate elle veut sortir la
tête du sandwich pour voir ce qui se
passe
c'est tellement jeu
mais que je viens de réaliser que je
joue un sandwich en fait je te dire tu
le dommage j'avais jamais réalisé un
véhicule joue super bien tu fais le
panini
non
là je bosse sur la courgette voiture
philippe au fromage qui fonderait sont
pas dignes hellénique
elles sont pas lignes rouges pas c'est
ce que je crois et puis gagnent et
magali shantung aniche on a un petit
extrait
[Musique]
c'est la grisaille d'amis
c'est un match où tout ce que j'avais
et alors
je vais pas prendre je vais faire sa
promo parce qu'elle à l'olympia dans
quelques jours elle m'a invité même à
chanter avec elle cette chanson tu vas
chanter il faut aller la voir adresser
j'adorerais aller chanter avec l olympia
si je peux le faire j'ai vraiment envie
d'évasion
c'est une artiste formidable c'est vrai
qu'on attend d'un jour non non non non
non c'est vous ne la différence est que
lui sait pas chanter
non
je ne suis pas tanné vous chante bien
elle a critiqué nicolas kert elie semoun
respecte des trucs c'est non il a chanté
c'était drôle et il le sait il le sait
très bien qu'il ne sait que peu
tranquille dit non il a écrit des beaux
textes assez poétique et les doux et là
dedans mais c'est vrai que quand il a
chanté de la bossa nova il nous a
écoutés on les avait pourtant fait ce
personnage je suis sûr que il va nous
coûter quelque chose des lycées c'est ce
qui nous regarde et il est capable même
devenir est à remarquer quand tu lances
un extrait a toujours un petit temps ça
arrive pas tant alors je vais te dire
pourquoi
ban il ya des personnes en régie qui
sont là en emploi précaire
ils sont là aujourd'hui
ils vont être là demain
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans
mais voter vite mais il a dit roy
ok
pourquoi la plupart c'est exactement ça
c'est d'ailleurs en parlant de portable
on ne va récupérer ton smartphone ou la
récup et nora et très sexy qu'un oui je
suis en tout cas sur les justes et
n'aura que très sexy oui c'est pas
oublier oui mais voilà je tente un
voyage les mêmes sexuelle c'est parce
que c'est une aura c'est ton vrai prénom
oui parce que elle n'aurait on dirait
qu'elles s'appellent norah mais tu
l'appelles qu'elle est long
[Applaudissements]
je crois que c'est un traiteur libanais
c'est sympa pour les miches sur les
vrais merci
public il était mal est ce qu'on peut
appeler l'europe assistant pour
l'évacuer kehlois s'appelle galantine
après
le décor est garanti et glauque et moi
c'est toi
génial l'égérie non non non non on va en
faire pendant l'émission vous inquiète
on a des mecs qui ont vraiment du talent
gad on va que les montres et tu vas nous
dira si tu les produire et ou pas
d'accord kiev - durée ouais regarde
regarde martys vous l'avez connu l'année
dernière si vous regardiez l'émission
regardez ce qu'il fait c'est magnifique
on a des supers et ce clip
[Musique]
m
il faut
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est martin alors on a mon moment
préféré de sais ce que c'est bon tu sais
que les gars monde en paille se cache
mais le gars quand même c'est à dire non
mais on va donner beaucoup
il a dit je veux faire un truc les gars
si vous pouvez le trouver un endroit où
il ya plein de boîtes aux lettres
moi je le met de dos je vais chercher du
couillon de voleurs très vite ce voile
du courrier chez ma mère j'ai ma cousine
l'oeil avisé d'en tourner mais pourquoi
est ce que ça veut dire a recommandé en
scène
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle philippe lalanne regarder
si les places
[Musique]
d'avancé
ne l'oubliez jamais ce mois de juillet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chat il est au bout du rouleau
pourquoi et le dernier est ce que vous
connaissez la tribu de dana
oui
mais là là on a alors on a on a on a
pour moi on a le patron de la tribu de
dana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
jonnhy cabrel a fait partir ils ont
gardé restore cce
non il peut passer en chine bat et les
paroles comme il ya trois mois
[Musique]
chauffez jeu
chauffer les cougars je sais que tu as
un talent c'est que tu sais très bien
chanté changer les paroles genre tu
donnes une chanson tu peux nous faire la
tribu de dana avec d'autres paroles
enfin là c'est parce que je les connais
pas à la base et quand je pense ceci je
danse l'asie qu'est ce que tu peux faire
un truc comme ça sur la tribu de dana
je peux essayer mais alors normalement
il ya un petit temps de latence quand
ils vont lancer l'adisq la musique tu
sais que attendu c'est que ce truc là je
le fais depuis que je suis petit c'est
un jeu que je faisais à l'école où
j'essaie de parler aux profs avec un
français presque bien qui fait croire
que peut-être j'ai dit un vrai truc là
depuis de ce gamin parce que j'avais pas
le courage d'être méchant vraiment donc
j'étais un peu manipulateur tu vois je
faisais monsieur et oui elle m'a l'air
est ce que par exemple en 44 il y avait
des sera vernie souvent et pasky tu vois
c'était un peu une arnaque et matthew la
tribu de l'ain tu dis ce que tu vas y
balancer le sont celles de ses
programmes
v
non
[Musique]
avaler dans la jeu le temps que des
boyaux jeu
je sors
et en selle
davie doit
tu te bats
[Musique]
m
je n'ai aucun cd rom est ce que tu peux
faire est ce que tu peux me faire tester
willem double jeu non adieu les magic de
besoin si la plupart la musique est ce
qu est l église
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benoît c'est comme ça deux collègues
tout ça
la passion chez vous le mec qui va
vraiment éclats cet oiseau est ce que tu
veux que je te dis vive c'est bon je
vois ça en recrutant au loin d'avoir un
gad elmaleh et reste avec nous jusqu'à
la fin de l'émission
et là tout de suite ça va gueuler un
petit peu parce que c'est le jeu zappé
je matais partie
vont lancer le jingle c'est juste qu'ils
n'ont mais c'est juste là il s'entend au
téléphone ouais tu sais quand tu y as
tricks et toi là pas du tout pas du tout
les chansons ils parlent tous les deux
d'un autre truc tu n'es pas d'échalotes
dans les médias nous là qui veut qu'on
lance le jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dir
chaque jour je zappe ce matin sur http
mp ou sur la boudeuse émission touche
pas nombreuses brèches
on va parler de danse avec les stars
c'était la reprise samedi soir carton
d'audience 28% de part de marché
strambio 8,38 sur les ménagères et 38,6
millions 800 ouvriers téléspectateurs
ils ont écrasé le plus grand cabaret du
monde qui a fait en plus un score
correct on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble et danse avec les stars sur
tf1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
christa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fête du malheureux
[Applaudissements]
le pas de gérard vivès je pense qu'on va
se remettre avant la prémonition
c'est sur ces deux côtés est-ce que vous
aps que vous m'aviez vous avez vos
pancartes alors ça ça passe ça ma tasse
samassa matin je vais démarrer
je vais démarrer par celui qu un petit
peu lancer cette émission abbaoui puis
je travaille dessus alors les deux
qu'ils avaient maté danse avec les stars
soit parce que c'est archi positives
c'est archi c'est grand public c'est
fédérateur c'est pour tout le monde et
puis d'ailleurs 38 ménagères ça prouve
que 38 ménagères et 28 individus je
parle aux connaisseurs en train de
passer à 5 non mais ça pardonne pas
bonjour est ce vraiment savoir pourquoi
vous maintenant la droite non
le concept en lui-même serait déjà un
peu un non-sens morgan un documentaire
sur le pérou ça donne envie d lopper ou
éventuellement quand on regarde les gens
mangent effaré cuisine que ça donne
envie de manger quand elle les gens
chanter on a envie de chanter mais la
regarder les gens danser le charleston
et où chacun profite c'est pas mal
des amis et on y tient ce soir
j'aimerais bien la regarder des gens
danser le charleston mais évidemment non
ça n'est pas moi jamais eu un pote m'a
dit ce soir au matin trucs sur le perron
[Applaudissements]
je veux défendre jean michel maire c'est
vrai qu'on se dit des personnes qui
dansent pour nous tout le monde danse
bien on n'arrive pas à percevoir la
technique on se dit est ce que vraiment
ils dansent nous les zones il venait
temps plus les vedettes qui viennent en
plus je dois courir je dois honorer pour
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de danse mais pas
beaucoup de stars
mettant au pas tous ce que c'est
vraiment le bal des ringards parce qu'on
ressort comme chaque année des gens qui
vendent pas de disque le real serait
d'ailleurs une autre émission que si on
vit ici on peut parler de toutes les
émissions servir comme sa démission
vendredi tout est permis
elle mentionne toute chose il m'a fait
hurler le 6 mai elle est drôle c'est pas
bien mais pourquoi est ce qu'ils leur
ils leur font porter chaque fois des
robes de tapis nos artistique on dirait
surya bonaly dans les années 90 est
hyper super pino jarre disciplines
artistiques en mai c'est à dire que ce
sont des prostituées surtout je crois
bien aux deux fillettes d'extensions de
cheveux de frison et de nos blanc nacré
sur les yeux c'est raymond grosse limace
et aux grands music hall vous avez vu
l'escalier ils ont mis des moyens sur le
décor c'est vraiment une très très belle
émission de la famille se déporter flou
qui va l'effort qu'elles forment ce que
vous parliez d'amel bent non la taille
ou la télé 7
ils savent pas danser donc ils ont fait
des efforts
que c'était cet été dans la bouche est
illégal
[Applaudissements]
exclu parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
les chercheurs etc
le rhum c'est un peu des rideaux de
douche en perles ça je suis d'accord
c'est aussi seul petit point qui m'a pas
moi j'aimerais avoir l'avis de
christophe carrière qu'ils appellent à
mios neigeuse a mené en fait c'est pas
sur le fond que je zappe sur la forme la
forme
hans hess savoure entre au bureau du
spectacle c'est à dire que c'est ou
c'est non mais tout et tout et tout
match c'est s'est laissé le bras
c'est incroyable c'est à dire ça ça moi
ça m'a somme j'ai un mal de crâne à la
fin de l'émission ça me réveille mes
acouphènes s'en saisir c'est terrifiant
on m'avait dit qu'on allait donc avec la
meilleure volonté du monde en plus bon
il ya vincent qui a voté que j'aime bien
mais il faut qu'il arrête la carotène
c'est pas possible un problème sur le
messie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien de sentir la meilleure bande de
l'émission c'est la crise de la
quarantaine et sécurisé la quarantaine
tu chose tu écoutais janvier après la
présentation par exemple des
personnalités et non pas des stars genre
y ait une voix off on dirait que c'est
qu'un salaire qui pourrait présenter la
pluie le beau temps je veux dire ce sera
un fait divers sans tête avait entendu
ce qui vole aux riches en pleine crise
est là je me rends les feux de ces
mangas chasse et christophe c'est bon on
va vous envoyer une aura qui va
s'occuper tout un leader un gars qui est
qu'il y avait tous les films cambodgien
elle café des chroniques sur des albums
de à oscar h 20 que double c'est normal
qu'ils vont pas kiffé ce paquet doit
aussi y aura ma danse avec les stars va
extrêmement bien produit ça se rapproche
énormément du programme dont ces issus
et le programme américain
je trouve ça extrêmement bien fait moi
j'aime beaucoup le casting je le trouve
très drôle ya quand même le rappeler
celle en délire de cape et d'épée je
trouve ça quand même assez cool il ya
amel bent évidemment paul heider était
petit mais mal peut-être pour gerald est
cela qui est un petit peu un peu
beaucoup d'humour
les deux bémols pour moi vraiment alors
vraiment j'adore cette émission le
premier c'est l'espèce de bande là
karaoké solognote celle où la série nos
fruits de reprise un peu en deçà ça
casse un peu le dernier trou pour le
deuxième le plus important c'est le
manque de complicité quand même entre
vincent en laissant à tester ils ne se
regardent à peine lui ils terminent
toutes ses phrases il ya une deuxième
partie de soirée après le prime où il
parle un petit peu il faut un peu il
retourne un peu sur le sur l'émission ou
là mais carrément il a coup il ya zéro
complicité je ne comprends pas pourquoi
l élégant est ce que je pense de réponse
de charles iv à ce qu'ils s'entendent
bien ou pas ils s'entendent à merveille
[Musique]
j'aime bien ils couchent pas ensemble
ils son collègue de travail
ils s'adorent x10 mini est enfin
week-end dernier ensemble un peu nagé
midi
je suis à la production j'ai rien et
truc que je peux entendre des trucs que
je peux pas entendre
c'est à l'américaine je suis navré
hilton en amérique aux papas les regards
de droit car ils ont un prompteur
ici ils font leur job il faut leur job
le pont leur demande de faire c'est
franchement lors qu est je suis navré
mais leur casting et tous les versets
américains français sur dix ans pour
qu'on danse du cha-cha-cha sur michael
jackson pendant deux ans et auquel nous
sommes même pas une aura et nous avons
écouté c'est normal c'est normal qu'il
n'y ait pas des vrais musique vous
imaginez en prime time sur tf1
un samedi soir à 20h50 avec des chansons
qu'on connaît pas les gars je vais faire
400 kg
karaoké aux états unis pareil j'ai
entendu dire que diam's allait la faire
c'est la vraie chanson est diffusée pas
j'ai une question à poser
j'ai une question posée à jean reno et
droit et arrêtez s'il vous plaît gérard
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas que c'était
jean pierre foucault qui devait
présenter danse avec les stars
absolument pas non non c'est moi qui ai
proposé dans ce sens a tf1 on voulait un
jeune animateur un nouvel animateur pour
un lancé un des animateurs jean pierre
lui ont été assignés c'était
obligatoirement un mec qui fait des uv
vous avez
[Applaudissements]
il a dit jean-luc n'ont pas d'accord ça
nous va travaille toujours à tf1 je
regarde parce que c'est vrai que c'est
positif amel bent alain passion qui a
été à son mariage
chagnon secrète et inavoués pour jean
marc généreux
j'adore quand il danse et entonne
brillant le pathétique une crise
d'épilepsie géant plaint du manque de
calme je dis ce que je fais c'est
d'accord avec les listes c'est vrai que
c'est assez bizarre quand d'un seul
crime est une danse du cha-cha-cha sur
gérault vient de guéret de jean jacques
goldman
c'est ça fait penser aux bals populaires
cantareil rock et à des vieux qui s'est
passé super maintenance et madison
c'est comme ça c'est un peu hors cadre
c'est le seul truc que je trouve
vraiment très très bien aussi c'est
passé vu le sponsor de la soirée il ya
des partenaires c'est la semoule de
couscous
gâtés je voudrais dire une chose moi je
matte
ça m'intéresse parce que c'est de la
matière aussi pour moi
mais je mate surtout parce que j'adore
la danse j'aime bien le show s'est bien
produit c'est pas parce que gérard
louvin en face de moi mais je dois dire
une chose c'est très sérieusement que
c'est un peu en force
de temps en temps je sens ce centre au
jeu sans trop de nous
[Musique]
surtout quand c'est les maîtres du jeu
évident
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il a vécu en direct en touche pas à
mon poste mais laisse aux lumières
j'ai fait mon service je vais
antécédents pas le souvenir à lavit une
flemme leur travail sont paroles
d'évangile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel bonheur
il est à côté de moi en ce moment parce
que je sens que des trucs qui se passe
et qu'on contrôle tous ici ça se passe
je suis ici tu pilotes et aidant plus
cessé longtemps bras et ses stars pas
dit si c'était le président teddy gentil
salat et monsieur on dirait que je vais
faire un discours il faut prendre les 45
millions pour agences
[Applaudissements]
cette même année avec nous ce soir et
gad elmaleh la fiche des seniors et
bientôt deux millions d'entre deux
millions d'autres et ça c'est une belle
expérience
bah oui ça j'avais des cheveux bizarres
dans ce
vous avez alors la ont réussi cet
exploit
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez
je veux pas traire
mais c'est carrément rentrer chez eux
donc de chez eux y voient la télé mère
[Musique]
était plié de 6 le nouvel hamstra dans
le sinueux 128
c'est une bombe atomique donc deviner où
je suis et je vous donne un indice
appelle les deux millions d'entrées
c'est un carton en plus j'aime beaucoup
le producteur de ce film
voilà que j'embrasse in the starry et
c'est vrai que ça cartonne non mais
c'est vrai parce qu'il est venu nous
voir en plus il est dans les pc par
rapport au seigneur je voulais juste te
dire que je ne suis pas venu les mains
vides comme on dit à la télévision
scheer sur la vidéo s'est jetée apporter
un petit cadeau non un petit présent
schalit ne paye pas de mine
je ne va pas chercher fleurette quoi qui
tout en acoustique
c'était une chose symbolique c'est que
c'est un cadeau qui est personnalisé non
tu fais désormais partie de l'équipe des
seniors
la loi merci
là
la rousse à brive
mon chiffre porte bonheur c'est vrai
puisque j'ai une renault 5 exactement
j'ai une forte pendant cinq voix je
donne trois types merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu es tout contenu je pense à
tes petites gens c'est toi merci baba à
ce gars là a ajouté mardi
je
il
les cowboys
lou temps
il savait quoi rester là et elle joue
très bien la dame au 15 mars
et lui c'est un grand d'italie
allez maintenant avec tout ça
shauna on doit accueillir philippe au
centre bell
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à les y réalisa alors lui il est
parti avec la guitare
[Applaudissements]
le retour le come back pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas philippe baudelle y sera
avec nous tous les jours philippe vandel
y voit tout et c'est tout il voit des
trucs qu'on voit passer ça cette phrase
est étrange parce que quand en général
on dit pour ceux qui connaissent pas
philippe vandel on parle de trucs qu'il
a fait lui il dit pour ceux qui
connaissent pas il va être là bas vous
allez tout net ce qu'il a mais j'ai
commencé par un hommage au parrain que
vous êtes vous êtes le parrain de
l'émission c'était sur france 2 c'est au
jt 13h un reportage sur les flics ripoux
de la bac de marseille
la brigade anticriminalité ils ont
interviewé un très bon connaisseur du
dossier et de marseille on va le voir
regarder avec son lot qui on valoir
avec son look et ses pouvoirs on
croirait tout droit sorti d'un film sur
la mafia pas du tout c'est parce que
vous croyez
ils dénoncent la corruption des forces
de police il est conseiller municipal de
marseille député européen d'europe
écologie les verts jamais vu un écolo
comme ça
généralement on va parler des vols de
portables et gadgets déjà fait relève et
votre goût et portables oui ils l'ont
retrouvé vous avez porté plainte ils
l'ont retrouvé
ils n'ont ils n'ont pas retrouvé et bien
voilà ce soir je me suis fait voler mon
portable à une terrasse de café
elle était comme ça m'a posé et détail
détails inutiles ont posé comme ils sont
chez eux mais je devisais game avec une
jolie damoiselle contre et il ya un
jeune homme d'origine étrangère
[Musique]
souvient comme si c'était hier
d'ailleurs j'ai dit quand j'étais chez
les flics d'origine étrangère et bien
qu'il me la fait tous n'y pense pas et
quand il dit qu'on les envoie balader
évidemment il est reparti à canarsie je
crois qu'il fait partie du réseau alors
mis sur le tri un gars qui sort le coût
de votre portable vous allez le voir il
est passé au journal de france 2 un
spécialiste qui sont allés interroger
regardez le il s'appelle christophe
soulez 1 et directeur de l'observatoire
de la délinquance il est dans son bureau
et derrière lui la mine affiche qu en
dit long sur son sérieux il à la
criminologie pour les rues le même jour
le force 3 s'intéresser aux vrais
chiffres de la délinquance ces vols de
portables et pour une fois une bonne
nouvelle en trois ans ils ont baissé en
2010 630 me français se sont fait voler
leur téléphone
nettement moins qu'en 2007 où l'on
comptabilisé 850 milliards sont passés
de 850000 ac 130 milles et france 2 a
également les mêmes chiffres
c'est le même jour à la même heure
regardez les vols ou tentatives de vols
de téléphones portables sont passés de
plus de 1 million en 2007 à 7 175 mille
en 2010
pas possible je voulais rien dire ce
qu'on a vu les images de l'arrivée de
garde si jérôme revon et ses caméras
peuvent leur montrer qu'ils arrivent en
voiture vous êtes prudent voiture ou pas
on l'a oui j'ai failli très prudent
regardez c'était tout à l'heure c'était
moi c'était beau et la régulation vous
avez reconnu cette magnifique ce
magnifique vélib bien sûr sujet sur la
prévention routière au jt de france 3 ça
se fasse en région vous allez voir un
papy cas pas peur de perdre de prendre
le volant pardon malgré son âge on sent
confiance admirer sur le mois et je
pense je prends mes dispositions pour
arrêter à temps il avoue quand même ne
plus avoir tous les bons réflexes sur la
route pour tout à fait un peu surpris
par un enfant qui traversent ou alors un
rond point
il serait non c'est magnifique philippe
bond elle est avec nous
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant cette émission en direct sur d8
c'est la première de touche pas à mon
poste et vous réagissez sur hbo book et
sur twitter merci l'oise auteurs il peut
reste à côté de moi j'aime beaucoup son
look
dans un instant je vais révéler son
identité à l'aeia stéphanois qui nous
dit on en parle du riz du hérisse les
eaux mortes sur la tête de christophe
carrière et les sont morts sur la tête
de christophe carrière c'est stéphane
bach qu'on embrasse stéphane bach voilà
qui nous envoie ça fabrice qui nous dit
les vannes de thierry moreau m'avait
presque moquée ses dires il ya elodie
qui nous dit le sosie de johnny qui
chante dans la vallée de dana est
magnifique on peut leur passer ou leur
laissera à la fin de l'émission finir la
boîte aux lettres en diagonale exhaler
ce qu'on appelle en chimie le doublé de
covalon ci donnera dans cette émission
il ya samantha qui nous dit danse avec
les stars c'est comme secret story a un
moment faut arrêter voyez donc il ya des
gens qui sont pas d'accord avec gérard
louvin voilà et certains d'entre vous
pensé que c'était omar sy ou magloire je
vous révèlerai en fin d'émission qui est
derrière l'auteur
attention c'est maintenant
[Applaudissements]
d'autres leur demandait souvent
déconstruit vendée
sacconi du poste au toucher
[Applaudissements]
les rats connaît des postes et avait dû
faire très très lourd vendredi soir sur
tf1 confessions intimes quel bonheur
on va parler de christophe il est fan de
musculation et de tuning
les deux en même temps il est passé dans
confessions intimes mon homme est trop
égoïste sur tf1 ils seront dans sa
boutique préférée pour faire le plein de
produits protéinés vous allez voir que
la communication avec le vendeur est
assez compliqué ils vont dire des mots
qu'on ne comprend absolument leur garder
ça c'est quoi ça les sportifs c'est pour
agir au niveau d'augmentation de tests
seront donc tes meilleurs libération de
consentir une augmentation d'à peu près
400 ce qui permet d'avoir une meilleure
généré sens musculaire et un meilleur
développement
ok d'accord et le fc pau col c'était mon
visa mais celle des mécènes
c'est une molécule qui agit au niveau de
l'ingénierie sens de la membrane
articulaires
pas sûr
nivet lycée par lycée il a redit le vent
quand il a fait des études de médecine
quand même à bien marcher ça oui à peu
près un million cinq ça fait entre 20 et
22% de parts de marché ça c'est quand il
sait pas aussi à vous avez raison c'est
ça c'est ça c'est sa série il ya
virginie la femme de christophe qui
trouve refuge dans les romans à l'eau de
rose et lui il n'aime pas du tout ça
coûte et serena santé le plaisir coulé
en aigle tiède et doré comme du miel
chauffer au grand soleil se provoquent
des contrôles eurent fait pas chier
[ __ ] c'est très bien je peux pas
regarder la terre et la lumière rien à
[ __ ] allez vas-y arrête de l'ia non
madame waskul m'adresse à l'armada voir
ces moments là je construis de trucs
d'amour ceux ci sont là oui ben moi
j'aime bien côté jean-françois
continuité machin de de cuche et aux
côtés des romans le prince charmant eu
tous ces découle tout ça aux gars mouche
en prince charmant et les gains pour tes
bouquins tu trouves quoi le nom de
l'évasion l'évasion soit sûrs quoi ça et
je m'évade va ce que tu dit evans fait
bon après à force de nous gonfler que
sont heureusement boys sont ou seraient
ils sont beaux ils enlèvent les
ambitions modestes
tu les vois en vrai ben non ils sont
tous bidon je suis refait ce bilan qui
sont mus y sont inscrits tous les goûts
tél
c'est plus que l'autre hausse c'est
chaud durée oui effectivement je suis
d'accord avec là pour une fois c'est
maintenant il dit reste presque
charmants là il est magnifique alors
regardez ses réactions face caméra
regardez j'ai l'impression que ces
bouquins que ordures et que faudrait que
je fasse un peu comme ces gueules en
fait les grosses tempêtes l'eau qui
kipré qui disait monts et merveilles en
fait
legault qui christau la meuf qui est
christophe dans une [ __ ] d'imagination
quand même c'est de la merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr que moi et moi sa femme j'ai
presque envie de l'inviter dans
l'émission ciel nous regardaient bien
quand elle veut et je lui dirai des
romans voilà j'ai des barbares à quatre
services et cd rom andrews d'évêques
déglingue un langage très châtie elle
tout ce qu'elle sait dire c'est pas de
faire foutu me permet toujours comme
quatre pages de plaisir merci jean
michel maire qui a fait une bonne
analyse de la situation du sport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
plusieurs lui beaucoup d'autres
j'attendais rien charleroi c'est le
transfert de l'été 1 cm puisque vous
étiez sur direct 8 vous êtes maintenant
sur des beats comment ça va ça se passe
bien ça va bien ça va bien on va essayer
de d'être je vous sens
je vous sens fort sinon c'est l'échec
est ce que vous pouvez le mettre en
forme est ce que vous pouvez leur mettre
un petit peu dans son environnement de
direct8 l'année dernière s'il vous plaît
vous avez le kit d vite s'il vous plaît
voilà
[Applaudissements]
le
j'avais commencé avec jeanne et vous
était l'invité de thierry ardisson sur
canal pour salut les terriens et surtout
pour assurer la promo de cette
merveilleuse émission qui touche pas à
mon poste j'ai regardé par conscience
professionnelle et on va pas se mentir
ras rien à signaler
vous avez fait le job des vannes des
punchline et vas-y que j'embrasse
roselyne bachelot on l'a vu tout à
l'heure
j'avais bel et bien mais le problème est
ce ça vous m'avez venir le problème car
il ya un problème c'est que quand on est
invité de salut les terriens faut rester
jusqu'à la fin c'est ça rené dosière
bonsoir bonsoir vous venez de publier
l'état au régime aux éditions du seuil
le dernier de vos livres consacrés à
l'argent public
voilà cyril vous avez donc dû assister à
la paix deux spéciales impôts et
gaspillages et une partie mal il a fait
3 sa fin qui avait l'appui iii v6 et un
débat passionné et passionnant surtout
pour vous cyril h report des images
intercommunalités et communes 743
milliards d'euros azur alors c'est
énorme
et donc si le rythme augmente moins vite
fait très facilement
[Musique]
il y a
[Applaudissements]
le visage que vous avez choper de cyril
c'est quand même très fort ce qui fait
dans ce visage parce que c'est je
m'ennuie mais il faut pas que j'ai peur
de m'ennuyer
donc il ya même un air de dire où je
dois tout à ce qui se passe en rdc pas
trop de trouver les filets chez fait ça
genre ouais enfin faut vérifier comme
elle s'efforce de vue bienvenue bertoua
d'autres choses oui on enchaîne avec des
images terribles c'était lundi dernier
17h30 sur nrj 12
des images insoutenables bonsoir à tous
soyez les bienvenus dans hollywood
bourse 2 le mcg à poussoirs gros soir
métiers vont soit une semaine une
semaine qu nrj 12 nous prive
quotidiennement de pied ni prix s c'est
long c'est trop ces [ __ ] honteuse et
l'a remplacé par la première rame de
nghi venu ça me met chômeuse dronne mise
en examen oblige c'est donc anne denis
qui assure l'intérieur de jeny priez s
quotidiennement dans le mag et en une
semaine l'animatrice est parvenu à
imposer son ton dans l'émission à
l'antenne
l'apache anne denis comme on l'appelle
un style très personnel pour m bonsoir a
tous un monsieur bonsoir à tous c'est
parti pour 45 minutes d'émission est
parti pour 45 minutes d'émission avec
notre équipe est toujours plus de scoops
de buzz et d'infos exclusives et comme
chaque jour vous pouvez interagir avec
l'achat des vous faire part de tous vos
commentaires sur le site nrj 12 point fr
et les réseaux sociaux
et pour retrouver l'étude de la série
rendez vous sur la web radio hollywood
girl 2 sur le site d'énergie
c
longueur lancer une petite parenthèse un
pas juste te dire que si un jour tu est
mis en examen je te remplace réussi
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait vraiment plaisir et non je
serais pas ce que j'avais pensé à
anonymous tombe et laisse tomber avec ce
rachat fait que là c'est une bonne
émission que je suis désolé mais ça
c'est de la daube après c'est pas de la
faute non assumé d'une humble crétine
qui a été mise en examen
c'est juste parce que là l'émission
c'est juste de la double c'était là et
tu sais que c'est que dans les eaux de
gaza des scènes d'intérieur à
l'intérieur de l'intérieur de la partout
où il ya un panneau sur le muret ya
écrit rend les routes
[Applaudissements]
la maison en direct ce soir audirac les
séries moi ce que je vous dis c'est
qu'on va finir en danse
[Applaudissements]
je te faire notre avis ce sera divers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]